we're now being told that that the folks
in California especially in places like
LA are they're getting fed up they're
fed up they're done they're they're
angry and here's a local Fox report
which is interviewing one of those very
Fed Up Los Angeles residents let's watch
and caught on camera at a local
construction company in LA's glasel Park
several thieves are involved and tonight
that owner tells us he's frustrated this
whole strip has been broken to our was
been broken Dee four times these guys
just gotten broken due 2 months ago what
are we supposed to do we're a small
construction company Ryan Bagley the
latest victim on this glasel Park Street
to get burglarized by several thieves so
many it's hard to count as you watch
them file into and out of bagley's
business Delta Construction in electric
they smashed into our gate over there
smashed their gate into here 15 dudes
come pouring in Delta security camer is
capturing the destructive Mayhem about
at 5:00 a.m. Wednesday morning the
getaway car this blue Kia Soul baggley
says was stolen from lapd's impound yard
the cops just knew that it was from the
LAPD in pound cuz of the chalk mark on
the window that Kia Soul taking out a
gate so the hooded suspects could make
entry hi you are currently being
recorded inside they took whatever they
could carry including music equipment
baggley and his brother former band
members stored inside you can hear the
alarm and spot a guitar stole six of our
guitars a bunch of Studio mics and stuff
like that rustled some stuff out some
some uh construction and our
construction side they stole a bunch of
tools thousands of dollars worth of
valuables demolished doors and Gates
Bagley says the alarm company woke him
at 50:03 a.m. when the break-in was
still underway and he managed to get
there even before cops but the suspects
were gone I came in ready to rustle them
out of there and just be like you know
I'm I wanted to at least take down a few
of them his business now boarded up and
baggley is fed up with the break-ins and
elected officials I voted for Karen bass
I voted for Biden I voted for Gavin new
I'm sick of it it's like at some point
you have to give me a reason to vote for
you again we're just do our jobs make a
living help our employees make a good
living and move on but it's really
freaking difficult to
survive yeah so I I watch that have to
say that uh and you know that I'm
obviously according to a lot of people
anyway A Cruel Heart person so maybe it
won't surprise maybe it's just that when
I say that I have no sympathy for this
guy
whatsoever
um any chance of me having
sympathy
evaporated with with his second sentence
where he
said if you want me to vote for you
again like how is that even a
possibility that you'll vote for them
again I voted for Karen bass I voted for
Newsome I voted for
Biden look I voted for all these I voted
again and again again for people that
have caused this
problem and sure I might vote for them
I'm willing to vote for the people that
have caused this problem again but you
have to lie to me first that's what he's
basically saying you know since roie
Wade was overturned the left has lost
their minds making abortion their
official Sacrament but the Grassroots
pro-life efforts which are now more
important than ever are booming despite
the narrative pro-lifers have not gone
away in fact they've increased in number
one of the efforts I support is 40 Days
for life because they're changing hearts
and Minds in blue pro-abortion states
with 1 million unteers in 1600 cities 40
Days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities 40 Days for
life has opened a record number of
locations since row was overturned and
they've grown in volunteers this success
has come unfortunately with new unwanted
attention from the doj 40 Days for Life
recently made national headlines because
they're suing the doj on behalf of their
volunteer Mark H H who is uh was raided
by the FBI we've talked about them on
the show they're going on offense
against our compromised FBI and doj you
can help them fight their ongoing legal
battles and pursue free speech for their
volunteers including Mark Hal by giving
a tax deductible gift of any amount at
40 days forlife.com that's 40 days
forlife.com let me tell you something I
have two dogs for some reason and the
magic power of rough Greens in my home
since our dogs are now healthier and
happier I figured I'd offer a Santa a
chance to borrow them if he needs some
real power on his sleigh this Christmas
and he can bring them back whenever he
wants next year even naturopathic Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough grains
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America before I started
feeding my dog rough grains I had no
idea that dog food is dead food it
contains very little nutritional value
think about it nutrition isn't Brown
it's green let rough greens bring your
dog's food back to life rough greens is
a supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle rough Greens on their
food every day dog owners everywhere are
raving about rough greens it supports
healthy joints improves bad breath
boosts energy levels and and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident Ru greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump trial bag so
your dog can try get a free jump start
trial bag delivered straight to your
door in just a few business days go to
Ru greens.com mat or call 844 ru700
that's Ruff greens.com or call 844 ru700
today so any chance of having sympathies
out the window that you that you not
only have con Contin to vote for people
who have made your life worse um but you
are apparently willing to continue doing
so and at least he's being honest about
it because almost all these voters in
these
cities have voted for the people who
have facilitated the destruction of
their own communities and um and they
they just continue doing it they'll vote
for them again they'll just continue
voting for the same for the people that
and it will never stop
it it is a it's a collective
CommunityWide
suicide that they have decided
to uh
commit and and here's the thing I can
be in some cases I can have sympathy for
people who uh who are lied to by a
politician you who fall for a lie that a
politician tells and uh and then and
then they they vote for politician
because they think a politician going to
do a certain thing he doesn't do it and
and they've been betrayed like in many
in some of those cases I can feel sorry
for the voters
there um now many of those cases like
you should have known that they were
lying to you so wake the hell up you're
the reason why I openly call for uh
restricting voting rights so that people
that are as gullible and stupid as you
will be
disenfranchised like I I I don't think
that you know for many of these kinds of
Voters I think you're so stupid that you
should not have the right to participate
in democracy at
all um but you know there are times when
even intelligent people can be fooled
and lied to we we lied to so much that
can be overwhelming but here's the
point these people that are running
California and running Los Angeles and
San Francisco and the
they're not even really
lying okay they're not even pretending
that they're going to clean up the
cities these these aren't broken
promises no these are promises
fulfilled they are keeping their
promises you know none of these people
have even claimed that they're not out
there saying look I'm going to clean up
the streets we're going to get rid of
these criminals we're going to we're
going to Tamp down on this it's going to
be there a law and order Justice
truth justice in the American way like
they're not running based on
that like I said if they
were and then and and you had a
politician who was who was pretending
that he was going to you
know throw the book at these criminals
and clean up the streets and he's saying
all the right things and then you vote
for him he doesn't do it yeah I could
have some
sympathy but think like Gavin Nome has
Gavin Nome even
pretended that he's going to try to
protect your business from being um
raided by 15 hoodlums in the middle of
the
night no what you get from people like
Gavin Nome and Karen bass and all the
rest of them
Biden is either they deny you know the
problems that you're having your
community they deny it so you're crying
out and saying this is happening in our
community it's falling apart and and and
they're just they got the blinders on
and the the ear plugs in and they're
pretending they can't see or hear
you or in some cases they're openly
justifying
it you know Alexandro keso Cortez saying
that the looters are hungry and want
bread even as we see the videos of them
you know running out of a stores with
handfuls of clothing and shoes and
liquor not
bread
so these voters are not really being
fooled they're not actually being lied
to they are getting
exactly what these leaders promised
them which was which was more
chaos and a community that is less
livable if you like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed